الامان الخصوصيه الرسائل الخطره مفاتيح
اساسيه كانت محطه نقاش بعد استحواذ ايلون
ماسك على منصه تويتر قرارات متسارعه
للملياردير الاميركيه فتحت جدلا واسعا بين
الخبراء ومستخدميه تويتر لكن قراره الاخير
باصدار عفو عام عن الحسابات المجمده كان
الابرز موافقه اغلبيه مستخدمي العصفور
الازرق على استفتاء ماسك حول فك حظر
الحسابات المجمده لا تعني موافقه الجميع
او انه قرار لا يتحمل عواقبه
خطط والون ماسك قد تهدد بعوده خطابات
الكراهيه الى تويتر
حتى قبل تحركات اعاده الحسابات المحظوره
الا ان ذلك القرار انذار بعوده الدعوه
للعنف الا ان المالك الجديد لتويتر لديه
وجهه نظر اخرى لخصها بالارقام بحسب
احصاءات نشرها ماسك عن انجازات منصه منذ
استحواله عليها فبات خطاب الكراهيه على
تويتر اقل بقرابه الثلث اعتبارا من الثالث
عشر من نوفمبر مقارنه بمنتصف اكتوبر من
العام الماضي اي انخفاض من 10 ملايين الى
مليون ونصف المليون
المتابعون لشؤون تويتر يرون ان السياسات
الارتجاريه التي اتخذها ماسك في المنصه
ستعود عليه بالسلب خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالتحكم في حريه التعبير والمعايير
المنظمه لها فكيف لتويتر ان تطبق قواعد
المحتوى في وقت يعفو فيه مصر عن حسابات
المحظوره لاسباب بعضها يتعلق بخطابات
الكراهيه والعنف من جهه ومن جهه اخرى موجه
من الطرد والاستقالات ادت لتقليس عدد
الموظفين بشكل كبير جزء منهم وظيفته
الاساسيه مراقبه واتخاذ اجراءات ضد
الحسابات المخالفه للقواعد